Speaker 1: Let's take a look at the latest
between Chris Christie and the failed twice
indicted, twice impeached former President
Donald Trump.
As you may remember, Donald Trump attacked
Chris Christie for his weight.
Listen.
Chris Christie is obese, There's no question
about it.
But as I said at the time, several weeks ago,
Donald Trump is also obese.
And one of the real signs of a cult leader,
as is Donald Trump, is that a cult leader
can criticize others for things that they
themselves could be criticized for, And their
followers don't care about the double standard.
They don't care about the person in a glass
house throwing stones or the pot calling the
kettle black or whatever phrase you want to
use.
Here is Chris Christie asked on Fox about
the fact that Trump goes after him for his
weight and Chris Christie points out Trump's
fat, Trump is also fat.
Once Trump started.
Speaker 3: Hitting back at you on a number
of fronts, he took aim at your weight.
What was your reaction to that?
Speaker 2: I was like, he saw it on us.
I mean, please.
You know, look, Howie, there are tens of millions
of Americans out in your audience watching
right now who, like me, have struggled with
their weight.
True.
I continue to struggle.
I continue to try to do better.
I mean, so do they.
And what's that got to do with my competence
for office?
I ran the governorship in New Jersey for eight
years, I think in a very energetic, successful
way.
Responded to Hurricane Sandy, working 20 hours
a day for weeks.
I don't know what his point is.
You know what it is?
It's like a child.
It's a bully on the schoolyard who teases
you and makes fun of you.
But here's my message to him.
I don't care what he says about me.
I don't care what he thinks about me.
And he should take a look in the mirror every
once in a while.
Maybe he dropped the weight thing off of his
list of criticisms.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: So Chris Christie is completely
correct.
Of course.
You might remember that at one point Donald
Trump published this totally corrosive troth
to troth, essentially where Trump said, quote,
How many times did Chris Christie use the
word small?
Does he have a psychological problem with
size?
Actually, his speech was small and not very
good.
Okay.
He goes on.
He also posted this Photoshopped meme from
Chris Christie's campaign, open or town hall,
where it looks like Christie is at a buffet
of some kind holding like a massive plate
of food.
And there's a million other examples of this.
Trump's obese.
Remember that Trump claimed, with the help
of Dr. Ronny Jackson, to weigh to 39 and be
six foot three inches tall.
We know that Trump is not six feet three inches
tall.
When you see him standing next to a Tom Brady,
for example, or you see him standing next
to Barack Obama, now you realize that Trump
is very much not six three, just being shorter
than six.
Three alone would make him obese.
Also, nobody believes he weighs 239.
Somewhere in the two 6270 range seems to make
a lot more sense.
So Trump is obese.
But the point here is this is what cult leaders
get away with.
The cult followers allow you to criticize
others for things that are also characteristics
about you.
Chris Christie is right to point out to the
Fox News audience Trump is also fat.
Now, sure, Chris Christie is more visibly
obese than Trump, There's no doubt about it.
But the point I think would be best made here
is to turn this into a losing argument.
Instead of saying anything, I'll say, okay,
yeah, I'm overweight, so's Trump.
So we're tens of millions of Americans.
Is this really the issue that we have facing
us now?
We'll talk about how Chris Christie's polling
has improved and it has improved, but is it
really going anywhere viable?
We don't really know the answer to that.
We'll see what the reaction is to this latest
commentary from Chris Christie.
But Chris Christie is right.
Trump's obese.